نحن الان على مشارف مدينه شيبكينا وهذه هي
اخر نقطه يمكن الوصول اليها طبعا للوضع
الامني في المنطقه التي تشهد موجه ضربات
تعد الاعنفه خلال فتره الصراع ذوي
الانفجارات يسمع بين الفينات والاخرى
وتصاعد اعمده الدخان في عده مناطق حكومه
اقليم تتحدث عن صعوبه اجلاء كل الراغبين
بالخروج من مدينه شيبكينا بالحافلات طبعا
لكثافه الضربات كما نلاحظ الطريق الواصله
بين الشيبكينا
فارغه تماما حكومه الاقليم قامت بانشاء
حواجز عده في العديد من النقاط لمنع دخول
السيارات نحو المناطق الساخنه وضع الاقليم
يزداد سوءا حسب روايه سكان مدينه شيبكينا
واللاجئين في بيل جراد وحسب روايه السلطات
الرسميه عبد الجواد الروش لقناتي العربيه
والحدث
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات